[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to our talk
on persistent memory now I'm gonna ask a
question and I want to see a lot of
raised hands or you're gonna hurt my
feelings I love this guy
all right so how many of you remember a
world before the cloud and before data
thank you all right so our world is
changing and I'm gonna tell you a
personal experience going to the Grand
Canyon with my brother father mother
summer vacation when I was growing up
and we went to go to the Grand Canyon
and dad says hey kids let's get in the
station wagon with the wood paneled
sides and let's go get a triptych how
many of you know what a triptych is oh
oh now I'm really old okay so you would
go to Triple A they would print out the
route that you were gonna go and they
would help you map along the way what
you wanted to stop out what was along
the way and you'd get this book of maps
for the whole trip we thought that was
so cool and that's what we were doing in
that world we were not generating
mountains and mountains and mountains of
data like we are today fast-forward to
MapQuest I thought that was the best
thing since sliced bread right I could
print out on demand where I wanted to go
so I was starting to consume data but I
was just at the tip of the iceberg and
then we had turned by turn directions
for those of you that are directionally
challenged that was life-changing I
don't go anywhere without my phone add
to that now the world of ways where
we're crowdsourcing the data
we're actually generating data as we
drive for the rest of the world so you
guys know where I'm going with this
story
so let's look at the amount of data
that's being produced as we speak in
today's day and age I quote these
numbers over and over again because they
give them to me in a slide to quote but
let's think about what we're doing with
that data
there's zettabytes of data that
businesses are producing but we're not
able to take advantage of it because
it's just sitting in repositories and
it's a liability rather than an asset we
believe we have a technology that can
help us on the journey to changing that
so that when we reach 175 zettabytes in
2025 the world is able to process every
inch of that data make smarter decisions
and do more with that data so I'm going
to talk to you about the most loved
memory storage hierarchy we've all seen
it a million times I've had it drawn
this way in particular because we tend
to think of it as a continuum but it's
not really a continuum there's big gaps
in performance and in cost as you jump
between DRAM and storage and which is
the fast order then down to tape and
hard drive and for 50 years the
architects of the world have had to
adjust the way that they program to
minimize their memory usage because it's
very expensive and the capacity is
limited we also see that DRAM isnt
scaling at the same rate that our data
is and so what if we could have this
amazing technology where we could have
you know double triple the capacity give
up very little of the performance and do
it in an affordable way that seems like
a dream come true and today I'm here to
announce we just went live last week
this is a half a terabyte in my hand who
ever thought we would see that day and
this is now broadly available with Intel
Xeon cascade Lake CPUs and we believe
that we're going to be changing the
world with this technology we're just
beginning on the journey so I'll tell
you a little bit about it it comes in
modules one to one
eight 256 and 512 gigabyte to help level
set you know 32 gigabytes to maybe 64 is
kind of a sweet spot for today so it's
much higher capacity it also has the
ability to be spoken to in either memory
language or storage language so it's
byte addressable and bit addressable in
in 4k blocks it has multiple modes we
have a memory mode and an app direct
mode and I'll talk to a little bit about
that because I know several of you in
the room are developers and you want to
know what this means for you and it's
natively persistent so the data is at
rest in the CPU block that changes the
way we think about our data it's also
highly secure we have hardware
encryption it fits in ddr4 dimm slots
and it's also physically the same form
factor so it's not terribly intrusive to
the system designs that we have today so
let me touch a little bit on the modes
we have an app direct mode and that just
basically means that the application is
able to smartly place the data where it
belongs if it's hot data that's being
used on a regular basis it can reside in
the DRAM if it's holder data or cooler
data it can reside in either the Apache
path I should have just started to call
it by its code name in the Intel obtain
DC persistent memory or in storage and
we have a whole range of is V partners
that are helping to redefine and
redevelop the architectures of their
software to take advantage of this new
capability the application and the OS
actually see two separate distinct pools
of memory and and that's what is
encompassed in the app direct when you
look at memory mode we have this mode
for applications that haven't yet been
optimized to take advantage of the
capability and so what we like to say is
that it's fairly easy to get in and try
the technology the application and the
OS C
a single pool of memory like it always
does and it doesn't realize that the
DRAM that's installed with the OP team
DC persistent memory is actually being
used as a cache to help speed things up
so it's fairly transparent you don't
always get the maximum benefit of the
technology when you're in memory mode
you know you get that best performance
you want to be OP direct an app direct
optimized but this allows you to get in
and try the technology and still take
advantage of the capacity and the
affordability that the product brings so
when you look at the new way that we
envision the memory storage hierarchy
you can see that we put the obtain DC
persistent memory right in that large
gap that existed between the storage and
the memory we also have lots of
improvements that Intel's been making in
our three demand SSDs and this same
media is available in a solid state
drive form factor as well and so we're
working on really giving the architects
and software developers of the future
that full range of products to design
around alright so when I'm talking to
people about this technology sometimes
it takes a little while to grasp what it
means when you move between these
different types and tiers of memory and
storage so we'd like to think about it
in terms of what problem are we trying
to solve
if you've ever said to yourself wow
ibrahim is so expensive i wish i could
afford to put you know more data in
memory but I just can't then this has
the ability to help save money if when
you pair it with DRAM you also have the
ability to improve your memory to Core
ratios you can do more with existing
infrastructure and then in the app
direct mode that we talked about if the
solution is optimized you also have the
ability to really help break the
performance barriers that you were
seeing if your application was memory
limited and you can see a lot more
performance
so I have one final slide I want to talk
to you about the partners that we're
working with in the cloud to provide
ecosystem support for this technology
yes I said it Intel is innovating on the
software side it's really important that
we because we need the ISP partners to
be on board we need the service
providers to be on board and the OEMs
have to be on board you need all of
those elements for the solution we've
been working over a decade to make sure
that we have all of the pieces pulled
together for this solution and these are
some of the key partners that we've been
working with over the last several years
you hear us talk a lot about sa P HANA
but we have a lot more beyond that we're
working with SAS all of the is V and OS
v providers as well as our partners here
at Google so I'm gonna bring up on stage
today next and I thank you guys for your
time today is gonna talk to you about
what Google is doing with us so I hope
you guys can hear me because I can't
hear myself I hope I can keep your
attention while the band is playing back
there so Christie talked about the
memory technology and the landscape in
general I am hoping to let you know
about what how this how this technology
is actually realizing you who go cloud
and how you can go and use it and what
are the different use cases that we've
been experimenting with so we partnered
with Google around three years ago
around this technology to bringing it to
Google cloud and they announced it back
in March of life I'm sorry the November
of last year and that was actually a few
months before our own product launch so
there weren't a lot of work from both
sides engineering work into bringing
this product into market so they were
the first cloud service provider to
bring this into market
if you look at what this technology
translates to in terms of the VMS that
you have in Google Cloud basically this
is providing more memory for you if you
look at the VMS that are enabled by this
obtain memory versus the previous
generation there's actually 4x more
memory per VM that that dis enables so
more memory that is faster than SSD
that's sitting closer to your compute
and it's basically persistent right so
that's just putting all of that together
it creates a lot of different use cases
that are interesting to enable some of
the use cases use the persistence of the
memory some don't so if I were to talk
about some of the use cases that we've
been exploring one of the main ones is
basically because you have this memory
that's per VM that's close to your core
you can actually use this as some sort
of a cash for your i/o intensive
applications right so this would prevent
you from going back to back and forth
between the i/o and the i/o latency is
going to be prevented so that's one of
the use cases we've actually done some
experimenting with that use case we've
done some spark sequel analysis inside
GC B and we've seen about 4x better
performance for large data sets another
use case that we kind of explored was
looking at the persistency of the memory
right so the persistency of the memory
allows you to basically keep some of the
key values for your data inside this
memory so when your vm is restarting you
would basically have the data available
close to you so you wouldn't have to go
through the whole loading of the data so
basically that translates to faster
restart times we've also looked into
that application for different different
in-memory databases and we've seen for
for one of the ISPs that we've actually
worked with we've seen the load times
going some from some herbs a little more
than 20 minutes to less than 20 seconds
so that's the kind of improvement
and then the last thing that we've kind
of explored in this environment is
basically the last value proposition is
looking at the memory size and how you
can condense more instances into one VM
so basically different residence so you
know if you have a database with
multiple instances you can compute you
can basically put everything into one
single VM and if it's especially if it's
not very core intensive if it's more
memory intensive you can potentially
have some cost saving there because
you're not paying for all the VM that
you would normally if you're taking that
much memory so those kind of summarize
the value propositions are inside this
you know in the Endicott environment now
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
what actually shapes of VMs these are
offered in so these VMs are both if you
can see there are two different VM
shapes that this memory is offered in
the first VM is a smaller VM shape it
offers 96 B CPUs it has 624 gigabytes of
DRAM which is tied with 3.6 terabytes of
obtain memory there is this bigger size
VM that actually has 1.2 terabytes of
dieren it ties that with 5.5 terabyte of
obtain memory and the totals of the
memories you can see six 3.6 terabyte
and 6.7 terabytes both of these are
running on two socket Intel Xeon
processors the next generation basically
this is the cascade Lake codename and
they're both single tenant today the way
they're offered meaning if you get the
instance you basically have control over
the whole obtain memory and the whole
the
use the two instances are both in after
ik mode Christie talked about after ik
mode I think and he's going to talk more
about the details of how to program for
after x mode but basically at very high
level what AB direct mode is is it's the
mode where you can take advantage of the
persistence of the memory so you have
the address space of the obtain separate
from the address space of the DRAM and
you can get basically the application
can get to choose where to write what so
you can have it have an architecture
where you would store your hot data into
the ramp versus your full data into a
capacity I said it code word so up to
Intel update the so basically these
these VMs are enabled in after ik mode
and you know we've been working with
different partners to enable their
application for this mode and we'll get
into some of the details of what we've
been doing just a quick note on how you
can get access to these VMs so that link
on top this is basically where you can
request access for an alpha instance so
these offerings are in alpha right now
Google is basically this is the first
phase of Google products when they
launch they go in alpha and then there's
the general availability this is the
command line where you can use to in
space achill instantiate these instances
if you notice there's a new flag for
those of you who are familiar with the
CLI that flag is a new flag which
basically lets you unless you
instantiate the VM the local MB dem size
and you can set the size this is set for
a 5.5 terabyte instance which basically
gives you the SEP 6.7 terabyte total
memory the instances are initially
available in Iowa this is US Central but
they're going to be rolling out to other
instances so if you're if you want to
experiment
this today that's the that's the zone
that you want to pick and then there's
always support from Intel and Google you
can go to that website for different you
know programming models if you're
bringing your own application to these
instances or you know you're trying with
some of the open source software's that
we've been working on so that's the
that's the place to go to get some
support
so now I want to talk to you about some
of the use cases that we've been running
on this on this technology there's a lot
of use cases and different partners that
we have that have been talked about
during our launch and you know the
collateral is available for you to go
review I would actually encourage you to
go and take a look if you're thinking
about your own application and you know
re doing it in the Google cloud
environment
but here I just want to focus on a
couple of use cases that we have
experimented in the Google cloud
environment and we've enabled in the
Google cloud environment we've had
access to these instances for a couple
months now so we've been running
different applications one of them has
been a spark sequel use case which our
teams have been running in the Google
cloud environment if you look at the
architecture and how we've modified the
architecture for spark sequel we've
actually created that OAP cache that's
sitting between your storage your Google
network storage and your compute and the
way that works is when you get a query
from your compute into the into the
aisle first time it goes to the i/o it
all the way you know all the i/o latency
when you get the query its then stored
into the OAP cache so for it so for the
next iterations basically you're going
to be going right into the octane
persistent memory so you're basically
reverting the your you're not seeing the
latency of the i/o so that's how this is
getting the performance and if you look
at the experiment that we've done the
performance is actually showing you know
around 4x better performance
this is not the final picture we're
still working on some optimization so
we're expecting to this number to grow
even to add two times what you were
seeing here but basically what I wanted
to emphasize here is that with these
with that package with the OAP package
in a spark Seco you can basically get up
to 8x performance improvement from your
queries what I wanted to highlight this
is for a case where your data is really
big it's not your it's a big data data
set it doesn't fit in your Durant it
fits in the cache I mean if you can
implement that same OAP on a dram the
data wouldn't fit on it you would fit on
there on the you know obtain memory on
the other end of the spectrum of cases
first part is the data Kay data said
that is small that is not that doesn't
really require as much memory for those
cases you still have the advantage of
the cost savings that you do because
your per gigabyte price of obtain versus
dram is is lower in Google cloud
environment so across the spectrum you
can see there are different value
propositions for the memory this is one
side of the spectrum and the other side
is the cost saving and then one more
note so this package the OAP package is
now open source it's available on the on
github the address is down there on this
slide if you want to download it and
experiment with it feel free so it's
it's there
and then another use case that we've
been looking looking at it's a similar
use case it's with Hadoop HBase same
thing so we have introduced this bucket
cache between the storage and and the
end of compute when you get a client
request from HBase client it basically
goes you can if you can follow that you
know number one that's the flow of your
request your client request it's going
into the you know network storage and
then the next time we're on when you
make a request from from data it's
actually going to be in the bucket cache
so very similar to the SPARC use case
it's just for a different different
application and then if you look at that
that's actually around 33 X better
performance again this is the case where
your data does not fit in a bucket catch
that's one on a daemon versus when your
data actually fits in to obtain memory
so 33 X for a better performance and
then on the other end of the spectrum
you still have the cost-saving benefit
for it for the memory so again this is
gonna be open source I think that's
that's the you can go to that you know
link at the bottom of this slide and get
the you know get the package so allowing
basically these are some of it is some
of the use cases like I said there are
multiple many different other use cases
that we've been working on we're going
to be bringing those enabling those in
the Google cloud environment we're also
working with different high speeds you
saw that on this slide there are IVs who
are taking our optimizations and putting
them inside their application and
they're going to be available through
those as we you know roll this product
out and as we roll the partnership's out
I think that's it for me now I invite nd
to talk more about the programming model
alright thank you so we heard from
Christy that there's this new obtain DC
persistent memory we heard from today
that it's available on GC P and so I'm
here to talk about you know if it's on
GC p how do you use it especially if
you're a developer you want to develop
say a nice cloud application that takes
advantage of Intel obtain DC persistent
memory so I'm a software engineer and I
can prove it because they told me to
dress up and this is what I wore so I'm
really going to talk to you about
software the first thing that a software
engineer would have to decide is well
how do I want to use this stuff and
really there's kind of two broad
categories here do you want to use it as
volatile it is persistent memory but
maybe you don't care that it's
persistent you just want to use it for
its capacity and so on the left side
I've sort of showed you you have this
choice if you decide just to use this
for its capacity you can do the lowest
impact to your application you can use
memory mode which Christy explained just
makes the system memory look like it's
huge right your application is not
modified in fact the OS doesn't even
need modifications for memory mode it's
completely transparent to software okay
so that's one way to use it but if you
want to do a little better job on where
data gets placed instead of Hardware
deciding what gets placed into DRAM and
what gets placed into octane memory if
you want an application to decide what
gets placed into DRAM and what gets
placed into on the update media you
could use the app direct mode but still
you don't care on the left hand side
here that it's persistent it's called a
volatile app direct usage and actually
it's a growing number of our use cases
use this method it's pretty easy type of
programming you just decide when you
allocate memory do I want to just
allocate from DRAM or do I want to
allocate from this other tier that
happens to be a little slower than DRAM
but it's a lot cheaper right so you put
a lot of big data structures into the
into the obtain media and then you put
the really
latency-sensitive hot data structures in
the DRAM on the right hand side is the
set of decisions you make if you decide
you do care about persistence maybe you
want to use this to store some in memory
data structure that is persistent it
sits there even if the machine gets
rebooted or even if it loses power so
again you have kind of two choices to
make you can say well okay I want to use
the persistence but I don't want to
modify my application for that we just
have the normal storage api's it looks
like a very fast SSD write the world's
fastest SSD you just use the normal file
api's that you're used to using they
work they just happen to be
mind-numbingly fast on the other hand if
you want to squeeze every bit of value
that you can out of the optin media then
you modify your application and this is
what I'm showing on the right here you
modify your application to go ahead and
map this this persistent memory right
into the application and then you get to
use loads and stores just like you do
with DRAM so this is this thing on the
right here it's the highest lift it's
the most change that you might make to
an application but it's also the the
most value that you can squeeze out of
the obtain media so when I started this
project a long time ago I knew that we
would need a programming model to expose
all the things that I just this told you
about we formed a working group in
sneaking industry association it's
essentially a standards body and we got
a bunch of companies to come and join us
in the working group that was about five
years ago now and there's over 50
companies in this working group now a
lot of them that you would recognize as
operating systems vendors and as ISPs
and what we came up with is this model
and I've I've updated the model a little
bit to use the term app direct which is
what Intel calls the persistent memory
that we used in this model and you can
see at the bottom here I'm showing all
the persistent memory installed in the
system some of it might be in that
memory mode that I mentioned before
that's transparent to software so I
don't have to talk about it anymore the
rest of it is persistent and you can see
we've added draw
to the operating systems this is all
true today in Linux and windows and
other operating systems I'll give you a
list in a minute and that driver exposes
things through this middle path here as
storage this is what I was telling you
applications can use this programming
model without being modified they just
think they're talking to a really fast
SSD but that's not the cool part the
cool part is what happens on the right
hand side of this diagram on the right
hand side of this diagram an application
opens up a file on a persistent memory
aware filesystem and maps it in and you
get this far right blue arrow that I'm
showing here where an application has
mapped the persistent memory directly
into its address space this means I just
think about this an application does a
load instruction and it gets a value off
persistence without any kernel code
running right there's no context
switching there's no i/o there's no
interrupts no kernel code runs one
instruction means that you're fetching
from persistence right that's pretty
cool so that all sounds great but does
it it does come with some challenges I
don't want to make it sound like it's
just the easiest thing in the world for
example if you put a data structure in
persistent memory you want it to be
something you can get to after the
machine crashes if you have a crash or a
power failure and so it needs to be
consistent now file systems do this all
the time right if you're making changes
to a file system and you lose power when
you come back the file system has a
journal or something that makes it
consistent but programmers are not used
to doing this with data structures that
they just created memory so that's kind
of a new kind of programming consistency
with the face of failure what you really
want are some sort of ways of
transactionally updating your data right
and and how about keeping track of which
people per system memory you've
allocated in which you haven't yet
allocated again that's a little trickier
than it is with with normal DRAM because
it has to be a persistent heap and so
what you want is a persistent memory
aware allocator to help you with that
also you know there are some algorithms
that are different in DRAM than they are
with persistent memory like how do you
what's the fastest way of copying bytes
to persistent memory
well we have we have different
instructions in Intel that we've gone
through and benchmarked and done
measurements on to figure out what's the
best way of doing a lot of these
operations so you you want these tuned
libraries so that you don't have to
reinvent this all the time and then
finally when you're programming in your
favorite language for example you're
writing a web-based application in
JavaScript you want something that gives
you access to persistent memory in a way
that makes sense to a JavaScript
programmer right you don't want to be
going through some weird API to call
some C routine that doesn't sound like
JavaScript at all right you want it to
be idiomatic you want it to make sense
if you're if you're writing and C it
should look like C if you're writing a
C++ it should look like C++ you're
writing in Java it should look like Java
so we want language bindings so you all
know what I'm leading up to we took all
of these things all of these
requirements and we decided that we
could build a atuned vendor-neutral not
just for this product but for any
persistent memory product vendor noodles
sent set of libraries to make persistent
memory programming easier those
libraries are called the persistent
memory development kits or PMD K there's
the URL up there P memmio and the slide
has a lot of information on it but all
of this information is on PMMA oh you
can go find it
you can see where the libraries fit into
that architecture that I said before on
the right see where the application is
now getting direct load store access I'm
not adding another software layer I'm
pulling in algorithms just what you need
right we call it shrink to fit pulling
in just the amount of software that you
need you need transactions pull in the
library for drehs actions you need
something to look like JavaScript key
value store just pull in that library
and so I've shown you on the slide what
several of the libraries are there are
some low-level ones that hide
instructions from you they abstract away
some of those hardware details there are
some libraries in the middle that handle
transactions that's pretty tricky
programming so we get a lot of use out
of that and then we've built on top of
these a lot of language bindings like
I'm showing you C C++ there's some
experimental Python bindings there's
some Java bindings we've been working on
and like I said there's even some
JavaScript bindings which are so new
they didn't make it on this slide so
this gives you a general idea of what
the persistent memory development kit is
in the ecosystem like I say we've we
created this neo working group we had a
lot of the operating system vendors
there so everything that I've been
talking about is available upstream in
Linux already I'm showing you the Linux
kernel version that we recommend up
there 4.19 there are two file systems
and Linux that are persistent memory
where ext4 and XFS are both already
persistent memory we're in Windows
Server 2019 all these changes went in
and the file system that's persistent
memory aware there is NTFS vmware
vsphere 6.7 and later also supports
persistent memory so everything that I
just said is true in a VMware guest
right including a program and just think
about what this takes to make it work a
program running in a virtualized guest
does a load that it's thinks it's
talking to persistent memory and it is
because vmware actually put all the
plumbing in so that it's actually
talking directly to the hardware inside
the guest that's pretty cool
there's a common distros rel and slash I
put up there and a boon to Java has some
pretty exciting changes coming into the
upcoming jdk release and so on
and what else I put on this slide is I
just thought I'd show you what does it
look like when you put all these pieces
together so we have a proof of concept
that we did with Cassandra and you can
see it here at the bottom it starts with
with exposing the persistent memory
using the persistent memory aware file
system that I mentioned before you can
see we use PMD K here to first abstract
away the hardware details and then
provide some transactions on top of that
we have the Java bindings the low-level
persistence library for Java is there
and then we made a persistent memory
aware version of Cassandra so what's
kind of interesting about this picture
is the app at the top has not been a DAT
modified the app is just talking to
Cassandra the way it always has but
Cassandra and below knows about
persistent memory this is really a
common
pattern that we've been seeing when we
modify applications for persistent
memory the knowledge that there's
persistent memory in the system only
goes so far up the stack and then at
some point everything above is
unmodified it just thinks it's an
operating as usual so it kind of shows
you so did i modify the app well some
people would say no because the app in
my picture hasn't changed some people
will say yes because the app is
Kassandra so decide for yourself but you
can see the knowledge of persistent
memory only goes so far up the stack
[Music]
you